berries are terrific and a sweet holiday
gift they also have delicious products
such as Christmas cake pops cheesecakes
and dipped pretzels here's the only way
to get this special 1999 Cherries
Berries offer
call 866 fruit
sorry
am I sell it
did I approve this this is ridiculous
who the is gonna buy this this
is the funniest
what Christmas cake pops cheesecakes and
dipped pretzels call 866 fruit everybody
hates I'm sorry 866 fruit 0-2
or even better visit berries.com my
apologies to berries.com I I didn't I
didn't look at the copy before I read
that this I'm too immature to reach like
that I'm sure you have wonderful
chocolate covered berries